[Music]
will soon be releasing his first EP
IC rounds
thanks to these free facilities at raw
material music in South London having
access to spaces like this has helped me
take what I like to call the first step
out the bedroom I feel like a lot of
people start their musical Journey with
just them in the bedroom maybe a pen and
a pad like that's that's about it and
that's what it was for me for such a
long time having access to Aurora's
allowed me to
to create a path for myself and actually
understand where I'm trying to go with
music and and the team here has been
incredibly supportive in supporting and
facilitating that Journey For Me
[Music]
funding from youth music is vital to
keeping the studio open but projects
like these are in Jeopardy the
organizations that we work with are
reporting huge challenges from the cost
of living crisis be that from the rents
they have to pay on buildings like this
heightened Energy prices and also you
know young people who are coming to the
projects who haven't necessarily been
fed but what we're seeing is that the
funding isn't available and from youth
music's perspective we're having to turn
down nearly 80 of funding requests if
the funding Gap isn't closed soon many
worry it will impact the next generation
of musicians
knowing that I was going to struggle to
have access to things like this would
have killed the motivation obviously I'd
have still kept writing by myself but I
don't think I'd been able to go as far
with music as I have but when I sleep at
night
next week fundraising gigs are taking
place across the country as musicians
fight to secure their future
Alice Porter Sky News